well actually I'm working on a book
about building codes which sounds deadly
dull compared to the the other things
that I'm that I've done but what I'm
what I'm interested in is injury
epidemiology which of my second books
about asbestos and fire and I'm
interested in how all the rules that go
with our built environment building
codes if you go out if you go out and
walk around in New York City or anywhere
just sometime when you're not thinking
about anything else take note of how
much of the built environment has to do
with protecting ourselves against danger
the curbs on the street the lines that
are painted on the street the traffic
signals all the signs these are all
aspects of the built environment that
that help keep our our death rate down
and parts of the world where they don't
do that kind of thing or where they
don't they don't read the signs or pay
attention to them and they're
unfortunately a lot of places like that
they have the signs but they don't read
them or pay attention they have a much
higher death rate and it's a much more
serious and somber or subject than they
use other thing I sort of go back and
forth between death and destruction and
fun and games and you know it kind of
keeps like I life interesting I think
that the most fascinating thing about
about the work that I'm doing now that
strikes me that I think that the most
interesting insight is that it's not so
much having a democracy that makes those
codes those building codes and safety
codes work it's the habit of democracy
that just you know making your country a
democracy you know it doesn't inculcate
that have a book we're accustomed to
like you know our in elementary school
we learn Robert's Rules of Order right
so we're accustomed to the parliamentary
procedure and and kids in Britain same
thing you know they know all about that
and by the time you know a few
generations are going by you're used to
the idea that you don't run red lights
you don't you know ignore signs that say
wrong way you know that you do you don't
cross that yelp the yellow lines
you want to stay alive and that that
that somehow is a part even though
although it's an ordering and some
people would say a kind of hegemony over
people's lives it really does seem to be
a tool of keeping people alive in
democracies on that it's a it's an
elaborate way of putting it but you sure
you you see what I mean that it's a it's
a lifesaver and in keeping people alive
is one of the functions of democracies